BASELINE.
>> Jim: GOOD CONTAINMENT.
THEY GIVE UP TOO MANY STRAIGHT
LINE DRIVES.
>> Dave: REID FOR THREE.
RATTLES OUT.
NEARLY TOOK THE REBOUNDNABLE TO
IT GO.
THIS YOUNG PLAYER, ZION
WILLIAMSON, IS SO ATHLETICALLY
GIFTED.
>> Jim: YOU HAVE GUYS
ANTICIPATING IT. GET TOO HIGH
OR TOO LOW.
>> Joel: THEY PLAYED MARCH 3rd.
BREAKDOWN, NOBODY ACCOUNTED FOR
BEASLEY, MAKE IT RATHER D'ANGEL
EIGHT IN THE LOSS COLUMN
FOLLOWED BY MEMPHIS WHO THEY'VE
BEATEN TWICE.
THERE'S WESTBROOK FROM THE FOUL
LINE, CAN'T GET IT.
REBOUNDED BY BALL WHO IS
>> Dave: TODAY'S POWERFUL PLAY
BROUGHT TO YOU BY DURACELL.
I THINK THIS QUALIFIES.
>> Doris: CERTAINLY DOES.
WE EXPECT ZION WILLIAMSON
INITIALLY TO BE A FORCE IN
TRANSITION.
ANY TIME HE'S IN SPACE, THIS IS
WHAT HE'S CAPABLE OF.
JUST WATCH THE RIM IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THIS FINISH.
FIRST OF ALL, PERFECTROM LABISS.
THOUGHT IT WAS COMING DOWN.
HOLIDAY ON THE PUSH.
OUT AHEAD TO HART.
BACK TO HOLIDAY.
HAYES.
>> Lamar: THAT'S LONZO BALL.
>> Kevin: THATAS AT THE STRIPE.
DETROIT JUST FOUR ATTEMPTS SO
FAR.
DERRICK ROSE OFF THE HIGH
SCREEN.
WITH MORRIS LOOKING FOR ANOTHER
TRIPLE.
>> Antonio: PASS BY HE CAME DOW.
>> Antonio: JAHLIL'S THIRD, AS
WELL.
A GREAT -- LIKE THAT'S HIS THING
BEFORE.
HE KNEW
>> Dave: STEPHENSON WORKING THE
PAINT.
BEASLEY COULDN'T HANDLE THAT
PASS.
GRIFFIN WITH A HEAD OF STEAM.
HERE IS GALLOWAY.
HE'S BEEN THE BEST59-51, BIGGES
THE GAME FOR THE LAKERS.
LAND ROVER ABOVE AND BEYOND
PERFORMANCE SPOTLIGHT.
>> Stu: THE PLAYS THAT HAPPENED
IN THE FIRST HALF, WE DIDN'T GET
A CHANCE TO SHOW IT THEN, LONZO
CREATED SENSATIONAL BEHIND THE
BACK PASS AFTER ALMOST TURNING
WITH NIMBLE FINGERS, TAPS IT
THROUGH. Dell: YOU DIDN'T?
>> Eric: MADE A COUPLE OF
THREES, AND THAT HAMMER IN THE
THIRD QUARTER.
>> Dell: HE HAD A COUPLE OF
GOAL OF THE BALL GAME.
>> Jackson: I LOVE WHEN IT WORKS
OUT LIKE THAT.
>> Jones: AROUND 13 POINTS PER
BUT THAT LONZO BALL BUCKET GOT
THIS BUILDING POPPING.
>> Jackson: HE'S GOT HIS LEGS
BACK. 5.
MINNESOTA TRYING TO SNAP A
LOSING STREAK.
ON THE ROAD DURING THE -- OH,
LONZO!
AS HE LIGHTS
OUT FOR THREES.
THERE'S ANOTHER ONE.
>> Kevin: DAVIDSON LOBS IT WELL
COUPLE OF THEM TONIGHT.
2 FOR 3.
KUZMA, BAD DECISION.
TEAM BY CHANDLER.
AND HARRIS AHEAD OF THE BACK AND
ALL BALL!
EJECTED!
>> Stu: LONZO DOES THATFAR, HASA
DEFENSE PLAY BY ONE LONZO BALL.
>> Bill: ABSOLUTELY.
>> James: THAT CAME UP TWO FEET
SHORT.
>> Bill: AIR BALL TAKEN OUT OF
THE WEAR.
AND LONZO OFF THE BOARD -- OH,
RANDLE!
>> Stu: THAT WAS THE LUCKIEST --
>> Bill: ABSOLUTELY.
>> Stu: THAT WAS THE A KOUFOS F.
>> Stu: I THINK JOSH HART GOT
AWAY WITH A DOUBLE DRIBBLE
DRIVE.
AS VOLKSWAGEN TAKES US THROUGH
THE GLASS TO SHOW THE PASS OFF
THE GLASS TO JULIUS AND SOMEHOW.
>> Bill: HE CONTROLLED IT PRETTY
WELL.
>> Stu: HE GOT AWFULLY LUCK Etu
DANGEROUS.
HE GETS INTO NO-MAN'S-LAND WHERE
THE BIG DOESN'T WANT TO COME OUT
AND GET HI ANOTHER LOOK AT THE
PLAY BY LONZO BALL.
WHERE DID YOU GO IS THIS AND
LOOK AT THE FINISH.
YEAH, SHOW IN  THE LAKERS TRYINT
THE LAST SHOT, ABOUT A THREE
SECOND DIFFERENTIAL.
IT'LL BE TOUGH TO GET THE LAST
ONE.
>> Bill: KUZMA, IT'S A IN NINE .
AFTER BEGINNING FIVE AND SEVEN
WITH LeBRON.
REBOUND BY BALL.
DOWN COURT PERFECTLY THROW SCOR.
KNOCKED AWAY BY NANCE.
LOOK AND HERE ON
THE THIRD.
LOOKS LIKE THEY'RE GASPING FOR
AIR.
JARRETT JACK DRIVES.
CAN'T HOLD ON.
CALDWELL-POPE.
SHOOT IT.
OH, WHAT A PASS FROM WITH
29.
AND LONZO BALL DOING A LITTLE
BIT OF EVERYTHING FOR HIS TEAM.
WAITERS GETTING 26.
DRAGIC, 27.
HOW ABOUT THAT BACK COURT HAD
>> Ryan: LOPEZ GETS HIT WITH A
FOUL.
>> Doris: MASON GETS HUNG UP ON
THE SCREEN.
LOPEZ DOES ATED SEVEN GAMES MUC.
>> WHAT A PLAY BY BALL.
NICE.
>> THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
>>> AY.
HE WAS A SECOND AHEAD OF
EVERYTHING.
HE KNOWS INTROOK THERE.CALDWELL.
BACKS UP.
CAN'T CONNECT.
RIGHT TO BEAL THOUGH, HE CAN'T
HIT AND INGRAM, THE REBOUND.
DOWN IS
FOUL.
LONZO BALL ON A TOUCHDOWN PASS.
>> Mark: THE PLAYS HAVE BECOME
CONTAGIOUS.
DON'T TRY TO DO TOO MUCH.
AND ON POIN